I absolutely loved the documentary
Albert Brooks defending my life uh and
thought it was beautifully done and what
was great was this has been long overdue
because uh your body of work Albert is
insanely uh rich and ingenious and
inspiring for generations of comedians
but it took a friend because you guys
knew each other you met in high school
right we met met in high school yes and
I you know we've known each other for 60
years and I always wanted to do this
when uh you remember the film My Dinner
with Andre when it came out I thought at
that point I said to Albert come on
we'll go to ad Deli we'll sit down it'll
be my lunch with Albert and we'll do it
and he never wanted to do it at that
point but then at a certain point I
don't know what made you change your
mind but we decided to do it and that
became the centerpiece of the of the
documented the two of us just sitting in
a restaurant and talking someone uh came
to me before Rob with the idea of doing
a documentary and it didn't uh it didn't
work out but then the idea see was like
the idea but to do it is good so then I
was having dinner with Rob and uh you
know are you do you ever want to do my
lunch with Albert and I said well what
if we combine this we do that and then
we also broaden it out and do clips and
talk to people well the absolute rocket
fuel
are the the bits and because the comedic
bits that you were doing uh they were
not they're
Evergreen kind of my you know it's my
favorite comedy has not been topical I
always thought what you were doing was
absolutely magical because it was
concept driven and every
single sketch bit that you've done
whether was on the tonight's show or the
Flip Wilson show or the Johnny Cash show
or I mean there are people who had shows
I can't believe who had a show everybody
had a show Conan O'Brien even Conan
O'Brien had a show yeah
unbelievable you said it Conan you said
it in the documentary that it was like
he broke the sound barrier it was like
Chuck joerger and they found a new way
of of presenting comedy and Albert was
well that's been misinterpreted what I
was saying is Albert's as funny as Chuck
joerger and then people took it this
other way um and who was funnier
Kissinger or Chuck Jagger I would Sayer
that's not the fair
thing but you did a kind of uh there was
a kind of Comedy that you start I I I
made up a joke the other day yeah Neil
Armstrong was at a party and told these
people a joke and no one laughed he told
a joke about the moon and no one laughed
and he said well I guess you had to be
there I was with you I love this moment
the first time I met Albert was at this
event and I'd never met him before and I
was and this I'll I'll back up just a
second because I was so relieved you
said something in the documentary Rob
that resonated with me which is I think
I've met everybody just about everybody
and I'm never intimidated I was
intimidated to meet Albert I was worried
about it I thought we're probably going
to bump into each other at some point
and I felt a little queasy about it and
then you say in the documentary that you
always were intimidated by by Albert
well I it's not just intimidated I you
just where is this coming from this mind
you never I've never met anybody that a
mind that works that way and other
Comics you know established Comics Larry
David in the documentary says the same
thing that he was you know so happy when
Albert gave him approval to a joke he
said or something like that you have to
understand I mean I in the circles I was
with I don't care who they were it was
Robin Williams Billy I don't care who
were in The when we got together and
people started spritzing when Albert
started when Albert went it was like you
know challenge dance when everybody's
challenging when Albert started
everybody backed off yeah everybody
backed off because they knew that you
know here comes the guy here's Babe Ruth
stepping into to the cage and and I
always thought it was a cool thing and
then when I got married my wife said
it's cuz you never
shower you think that's why they backed
off yeah yeah yeah yeah I remember
thought you had good personal it was so
funny cuz Albert was the first time I I
met you you won't remember this but we
were standing was someone's house we're
standing by a pool and you told me a
joke that you told me a story that was
really funny and I laughed legitimately
laugh laugh was very funny story and you
had some friend with you who I didn't
know and the friend just kind of shrugg
and said well I guess you had to be
there and you turned on your friend and
went no no he laughed apparently you
didn't have to be there and I was I was
in the moment watching uh you know I
remember I said don't you understand
that expression yeah that's when nobody
laugh if somebody laughs you don't have
to be anywhere you don't have to be
anywhere stupid man I don't know who it
was but uh forever in my mind I I
cherish that V but Albert Albert you
know we talked about this in the
documentary Albert would go on National
Television live television without ever
trying out the bit he was going to do
yes that to me is talk about working
without Annette I mean this is in the
case Annette Funicello which was what
would make anybody U good but no but but
no he
no but that's bordering on you had to be
there we had to know that reference um
no no but he he would do this and you
know we shared a house together and and
and you know I don't remember it exactly
but he did the first time you did the
Mind piece I don't think it worked did
it work the first time you did it well
the very first time I don't think it
worked it was the Steve Allen Show it
nobody knew anybody the point is he came
out he was doing a mime and he came out
in the white face in the leotards and he
never stopped talking it's so funny and
so it's brilliant piece and it didn't
play the way it should have and then
time goes by and I think you were called
to do The Tonight Show or something and
I said Albert what are you going to do
on the show tonight he says I'm going to
do the Mind piece and I said yeah but it
didn't get it didn't do well he says
yeah but it's funny I said I know it's
funny but it didn't get the kind he says
yeah but it's funny and that's the thing
that I learned about Albert which is it
is funny you just the audience has to
catch up to it they just have to know it
and Johnny Carson was hosting and he
came out and the same kind of thing
where they were a little bit hesitant
they didn't know Johnny went and I was
there Johnny literally fell off his
chair and the audience said I see yes I
get what this is a lot a lot of times in
my experience if if the audience is
looking at the host and they want
permission and that they need they need
permission and then they know
everything's okay and so um that uh this
that bit come out and you're talking and
you're describing I am now walking
Against the Wind I'm doing but then you
just it just goes into standup comedy as
a MIM about my wife and you know uh I
she said she lost 30 lbs I said look
behind you you'll find it and and it
you're in total my makeup and you're
doing it and and the thing is that uh
that I think when I when I talked in the
doc about breaking the sound barrier to
me it's about the level of commitment
and it's why I think it was no surprise
that you turned out to be of such an
excellent actor when you doing these
pieces I think there was a time in show
business where you needed to let
everybody know I'm in Show Business
these are jokes let's have a good time
nudge nudge wink wink and what you were
doing was this like dairo like
commitment to whatever you're talking
about you're looking down the barrel the
lens and you're saying this is this is a
very serious thing I'm doing right now I
really am the world's best pickpocket
and very good at it and then you proceed
to be absolutely miserable at it but I
think it's not it's the idea combined
with the intensity of the attack that's
what I always thought no one else was
doing yeah and now I think we see that
you know that you made it okay for
everybody to to sort of work I mean you
know with respect to people the audience
is the last to know anything they're
there you don't I never understood the
idea of doing it for an audience because
the audience doesn't know anything until
they see it so if you do anything they
haven't seen before you don't get
immediately rewarded like when you're
previewing a movie with cards the movies
that get a hundred are the movies
they've seen every other weekend right
they're familiar they're familiar
unfamiliar doesn't get a good grade but
it what do you do you just never do it
yeah you know it's the same it's the
same if we go into a restaurant and it's
a fine restaurant and we're served a
dish we don't know anything about this
we take the we take the word of of the
person who owns the restaurant and we
taste something we've never tasted and
if if the world didn't have that
possibility and by the
way I think show business is that's the
Holy Grail is no risk yeah and and I
think as algorithms get mature and as
more Executives get parking spots the
the the risk is less and less because
it's a business why do you want to take
a risk I mean I learned from Albert you
know when I saw how committed he was to
doing that bit even though it had when
we first uh screened spinal tap which
you know it was you know Albert had done
real life before that but this was the
first kind of about rock and roll and a
mock documentary and and we previewed it
in Dallas and people came up to me
afterwards and they said I I don't
understand why would you make a movie
about a band that nobody's ever heard of
and one that's so bad and I so it's like
yeah they didn't know what we were doing
it took them a while to figure out that
this we're making fun of this you know
and and I learned from Albert you got to
stick to your guns and and hopefully PE
the audience will catch up